la administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de eeuu dio el visto bueno
inocular las dosis de facer bayón t en
adolescentes a partir de 12 años
abriendo la puerta al regreso a las
escuelas ya que aunque no suelen
contraer síntomas graves
los adolescentes propagan el virus
sabemos que este es un gran paso para
nuestro país vacunar a una población más
joven nos acerca la vuelta a la
normalidad y al fin de la pandemia ahora
los padres y tutores pueden estar
seguros de que al tomar nuestra decisión
la agencia llevó a cabo una revisión
rigurosa de todos los datos científicos
se trata de otra medida para hacer
frente a la caída de las vacunaciones
diarias y también a los costos
logísticos que representa mantener las
dosis de las vacunas refrigeradas según
el 'new york times'
el índice de vacunación en los estados
rurales los más vulnerables es más bajo
que en el resto del país esto se debe al
escepticismo entre los ciudadanos que no
quieren administrarse la vacuna estados
como nueva york texas y florida tomaron
otras medidas
la gran manzana se abrirán puntos de
vacunación sin cita previa en varias
estaciones de metro de la ciudad y en
miami la gente que pase por el
aeropuerto podrá inocularse el ejecutivo
de by the end planea invertir millones
de dólares que incentiven la vacunación
y poder cumplir su promesa de inmunidad
de rebaño antes del 4 de julio día de la
independencia hasta ahora el 45% de los
estadounidenses ha recibido al menos una
dosis de la vacuna